the hungarian autocrat orban invites the
american fascist refuge in his country i
don't know if this is a sign that that
american fascism is obviously not
welcome here i mean they got to hold
their nazi i mean excuse me their manga
rallies their trump rallies and abandon
livestock fields because no one will
have them because they can't pay their
[ __ ] bills so apparently cpac had to
pack up and move to a foreign country i
don't think they're actually exporting
american fascism i think what they're
trying to do is import hungarian style
fascism they love this stuff ah they
[ __ ] love it so much so that the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
himself appears now most people did not
see this until it was actually posted on
a real social media app on twitter no no
one saw it on true social it's all
[ __ ] bot accounts over there they're
all [ __ ] fake either that or they're
just trump sycophants either way trust
me i know i opened up a [ __ ] account
on true social i'm on two social and the
minute i posted a video like it didn't
even go it didn't even have a chance for
the algorithm to pick it up they
censored it that's right true social
censored my freedom of speech so grandpa
poopypants posted on tooth central which
he calls it that he wants civil war
that's what it appears and of course
this is not surprising that a dictator
wannabe like the cheeto dust mobster
would post a repost or whatever the [ __ ]
it's called over there re-shit i guess
you re-shit it over there i don't know
you [ __ ] out stuff on true social you
re-shit it [ __ ] i don't know i haven't
quite figured out the platform yet it's
a complete copy of or it's a it's like
if you went down to the half-ass dollar
store and you and they ordered a
wish.com twitter and it came in a really
broken [ __ ] package that's that's
what that's what two central is
but on truth social the former dictator
wannabe he re-re-shit something that's
that that indicates that there may be a
civil war which is not surprising again
that that [ __ ] fascist would call for
civil war that's what he was calling for
in december of 2020 after he lost the
election got his [ __ ] ass stopped by
joe biden the american people said no
[ __ ] you don't get to be our fascist
dictator no [ __ ] go back to mar-a-lago
you [ __ ] snowflake and he just
wouldn't he wouldn't just do what most
decent human beings do because he is not
a decent human being most reasonable
people retire from the presidency with
dignity nope not a [ __ ] ounce of
dignity or decency in that [ __ ]
he continues the scourge of how he won
the election the big lie you remember he
called on all the proud boys and the
oath keepers which they're in the news
and they will continue to be in the news
for a long period of time here
especially over the summer but he called
on the prowl boys and the oath keepers
to come save him the moglodites the
trump humpers the maga fascist dark
manga he called on them to come to
washington dc to save his ass boy did
they try oh did they try on january 6 to
make sure that mike pence did not
certify our vote which is all ceremonial
in the first place we know this and i
think frankly we're going to hear a lot
more about this coming up in the month
of june as these select committees
become public and this testimony becomes
public we are going to get to see the
story of what actually happened on
january 6 but we know a lot they tried a
civil war they tried a cheeto dust
kangaroo coup we have people in this
country who are sitting in detention as
we speak for a conspiracy to commit
sedition against the united states of
america people who are not too far steps
away from the cheeto dust mobster
himself and we have more and more and
more people we had confirmed this
weekend that the oath keepers are
cooperating with the federal prosecution
of the seditious conspiracy where stuart
rhodes the founder of the oath keepers
was in charge of a qrf a stash of
weapons where his lieutenants joshua
james and brian ulrich were in command
of that qrf and joshua james protecting
roger stone and brian ulrich admitting
in open court when he took his plea deal
that yes he was trying to make sure that
joe biden would not become president
that there was not a peaceful transfer
of power is the words used in open court
there is a civil war going on now rather
you want to believe it or not there is a
coup attempt still in motion it's still
going they're trying to take over the
secretary's estate because frankly the
coup didn't work last time more like a
practice want run if you want to call it
that testing it out testing out the
waters find out where the rough patches
are that way you can avoid those rough
patches the next time well guess what
every time is the next time now with
these [ __ ] fascists every single
[ __ ] time is the next time
tomorrow we have the primaries down in
texas it is time right now is the time
to show these fascists who we are and
how we're not gonna put up with their
[ __ ] their hungarian style [ __ ]
not gonna do it go to the ballot you
vote vote vote vote your friends your
family your community members your
church members it is so important for
them to know that we are pro-democracy
here we are not for autocracy and
there's only one pro-democracy party in
this country right now unfortunately i
wish there was more but there's not
there's only one party that is
interested in protecting your liberty
and protecting your rights only one
jesus christ they're outsourcing their
fascism their style of fascism to try to
take your [ __ ] liberty the civil war
is ongoing it will continue folks and
it's gonna continue past trump the only
reason why he's calling for civil war
now or it seems to be that he's calling
for civil war is because he's [ __ ]
terrified he's painted himself into a
corner just like he did in 2020 when he
[ __ ] lost he seen the walls closing
in he wasn't gonna have the protections
of the presidency anymore he couldn't
fend off investigations and prosecutions
and indictments hell his way of life to
launder money may be in jeopardy so what
did he do he committed civil war on our
country he attempted a cheeto dust
kangaroo coup on january 6
their plan was not to transfer power
peacefully jesus christ they had a
gallows out front to hang his vice
president if his vice president didn't
do what the [ __ ] he said and they
chanted hang mike pence hang mike pence
hang mike pence you don't think you
don't think that's call for civil war
you don't think these [ __ ] trumped-up
white militiamen that were in flak
jackets they were ready to go to battle
at the capitol for what they seen is
their orange mussolini jesus you don't
think that is an image of civil war you
don't think you don't see it as
un-american you don't see it as
unpatriotic that they wanted to rip up
the constitution and wipe their asses
with it and declare donald trump the
king because they just can't handle
losing [ __ ] bunch of snowflake
[ __ ] is what they are scared
terrified and we could have him on the
run folks we already know that there's
eight million more of us than there are
of them already we know that bare
minimum we know there's eight million
more of us than there are of them and if
you don't think after that after that
vote in 2020 that more of those people
are on the side of pro-democracy well i
think you're fooling yourself but don't
get complacent this is not the time to
stand back and want fascism take control
nor the congress nor the senate nor the
governorships the secretary of state the
attorney generals jesus christ all the
way down to dog catcher if they have a
whiff just a [ __ ] stench of trump
vote them out it's time right now today
is the time to beat back fascism
you